hello welcome to reasons to say well we
give you reasons to see and not to say
Thor the dark world
let's fly reason to see number one Thor
definitely a Thor movie this is
definitely a Thor movie Thor is [ __ ]
awesome in this film you guys in the
first one he's like Thor the God of
Thunder for like a solid 10 minutes and
this one he is Thor that god of thunder
the entire time it's what you want to
see just him doing a bunch of different
hammer tricks flying around kicking ass
it's the e is the [ __ ] and he's funny
too ya know I mean it's it's it's a good
logical progression and it's neat to see
that sort of juxtaposition because the
first time you have him having to become
worthy enough to be you know Thor the
God of Thunder and wield that hammer and
now you get to see the full movie where
he's proving himself and now he is like
a tried and true warrior and he's pretty
awesome and you know it's like they got
the character arc of like is you ready
to be king is this what he really wants
and early on in the film you get to
check out this guy's hot ass frigging
body I felt like cheering when it
happened
yeah he is pretty ripped yes
sexy reason to see number two Loki first
Thor I didn't really care that much for
him I just thought he was kind of just
the slithering snake I liked him or the
Avengers I thought he I thought they
made an improvement but this is my
favorite portrayal of Loki we've had yet
he gets a lot more character this time
around there's a lot more depth this
guy's not just mr. evil guy and more
humanity to the performance and I really
enjoyed the hell out of him and he's a
total blast to watch well yeah it's like
you've seen him sort of come to that
place where he's becoming evil in the
first movie and then you see him get to
be a super villain in the second
Avengers and now in this movie there's
sort of that gray area in between where
he is evil and in prison but then some
[ __ ] goes down and then it's like well
is he really valuable and like the
relationship between him and Thor rather
than just brother what are you doing
this yeah because I want to is much more
this time
around it that is it's more fun to watch
there's great chemistry between the two
they bounce off each other better than
ever is my favorite part of the movie
was those two together and that's the
most interesting stuff you know and the
stuff that gives you the most to
actually chew on and pick apart is
low-key as a character and how he and
Thor play off each other and Loki's
motivations like that's the media stuff
reason to see number three directing and
cinematography I love the look of this
film a lot you know I seems a lot more
subtle the wide lens and it's it does
have that darker appeal about it after
all is Thor the dark world and this is a
sequel so it's gonna be darker
everything about it was just captured
excellently it kind of has like a Star
Wars and Lord of the Rings vibe about it
it's very fun to watch and you know they
got a different bunch of different
themes you're dealing with you know cuz
they got like humour they got a lot of
dark stuff and they got action and it's
all captured excellently yeah that is
interesting it's like this movie is both
darker and funnier light darker and
lighter yeah than the first movie it
seems to be paced pretty well and you
know it's all very snappy but it is
really well shot and well captured and
there's lots of really great stuff to
look at
is that a hundred percent on the tone
because it does kind of shift in weird
ways sometimes but it's a very solid job
from a guy who's done a lot of this kind
of stuff and you can tell it deals with
like a much bigger universe this time
around even bigger than the Avengers and
Wow just pulled off excellently you got
to give the guy kudos for directing an
awesome [ __ ] finale I don't want to
give it away but it's very creative
deals with different realms and worlds
and it's it's totally unique receipt
number for action and visual effects
like I said earlier Thor just kicks way
more ass this time around you know I
liked it in the first one because he got
to show he can kick ass even without his
powers but this time you get a same kick
ass with his powers his powers seem
necessary in this one and damn is it
just there's some moments where you're
like that was [ __ ] sweet yeah and
there's a lot of really cool action and
this movie is earth is almost an
afterthought it's like most of this
movie takes place either on Asgard or in
one of the different realms and that
opens you up to a whole different kind
of action it's like fat yeah it's like
fantasy adventure science fiction action
yeah it's like this movie Ryan to me a
lot of law
the Rings or something like that because
you get those sweeping sets armies
battling each other and creatures and
it's all captured very well and I mean
there's a reason we're sort of combining
effects because the effects in action go
hand in hand in this movie and they work
really well together you know and I like
that all the fighting that took place in
Asgard it did look a lot like Star Wars
and it I thought it was [ __ ] sweet on
like if there's any movie that's gonna
look like Star Wars it should be this
film it is oh just [ __ ] yes reason to
see number 5 the humor there is a lot
more humor in this movie there is a lot
of humor sometimes the humor seems a
little out of character it's a little
written yeah it seems a little bit like
a comedy writer came in and threw in
some punchlines instead it is a little
bit like hey joke time but there are
some hilarious moments yeah
Loki made me crack up a few times you
know like there are some really truly
funny moments and most of the time it
takes place within the characters well
see that's the thing is it is a bit
uneven conceptually because sometimes
it's funny dialogue hey hey and then
other times it's just like characters
playing off each other but there are
instances from both that still made me
laugh a lot even if I was like this is
silly I was still like but I'm laughing
yeah yeah check it out for its funniness
and I mean Aaron likes being funny you
know earth pretty much all the earth
scenes are a comedy routine reason to
see Dumbo 6 a Juris Elba the one black
guy had a scar one black one Asian guy
there's one black guy there's one really
fat like beard guy I think when he did
the first story I don't remember him
being that famous but he's caught on to
a lot more Fame since and they took
advantage of that this time around cuz
they made him away way cooler he's not
just some guy looking at the stars all
day and then you know taking the sword
in and out of that hole he gets to show
off his skills powers he's just he is
the [ __ ] especially there's one scene
you know and oh man just [ __ ]
dynamite man I thought they made a total
improvements all around they get they
advanced everything all around and they
even advanced this character well yeah
this movie does do a lot of giving you
what you want I guess because it seems
like Marvel really listened when people
were like dude result was super awesome
because he's always in the news
sorry heater stuff was like always in
the news for being announced for this
role or that role and he's been in a lot
of movies recently he's a really popular
actor now and so they were like we got
to get a more of this guy and it's
always a delight to have him on screen
it's a great science fiction actor from
Pacific Rim in this it's just like this
guy knows how to do this John were a
pretty damn wall well he's one of those
guys where it's like even if there isn't
a ton of scripting around him he can
still bring a lot of character to it
coming right after you know he's black
so black reason I see number seven
stellan skarsgård I really enjoyed him
in this because in the first Thor and
Avengers he's a very serious character
and in any movie this guy does she's
usually a villain or something he's very
serious character all the time but in
this one they totally tournaments like a
comedic element I thought he was funny
like the transition made sense to me to
make him funny III got a blast watching
this guy he was he was totally enjoyable
for me
I'm torn I'm still in scars ago because
I do enjoy him I do I did enjoy watching
him I'm a little I was a little bummed
just on principle that they were like
hey remember exhale vague he's just a
punchline now he's just here to be silly
but at the same time I was still
laughing I was still enjoying it well he
doesn't come more important as the film
progresses not really though because I'm
the family not even really though cuz
like that's still Natalie Portman
figuring that [ __ ] out yeah but there's
this one moment that I won't give away
where it's like yeah you've without him
that character wouldn't be alive I guess
reason to see number eight Rene Russo
she's not in a ton but they did some
things with her character we're like yes
she is Thor's mother yeah and how was I
was glad they delivered that because in
like the first Thor she's kind of just
the wife of Odin this one she they give
her not as much screen time most
definitely not as much screen time but
they did make some improvements I
thought on the character word with her
intellect and her skills
well yeah it's like you know she is the
mother of a warrior you know and it's
very it's made very clear by this movie
she gives a good performance but also
just the things they have her do it's
like they make her important even in a
hearse limited capacity and she does
drive the plot for certain specific
reasons we won't get into here it's
exactly like you said it's like there is
at least one scene where you're like oh
yeah
that's Thor's mother so she does a great
job raising a satyam a nine christopher
eccleston
he plays the main villain the dark elf
Malekith i think yeah and he was cool I
didn't think he was necessarily like
super special but what he has it is
technically great that what he does yeah
I mean he's not super written which
we'll get into later but it's like he's
still anchored the screen it's like I
wish they might have written him a bit
better but it was like I still really
dug his performance I liked just his
vibe and his aura and you know you could
tell he believed in it like he delivers
a really good performance with what he's
given and he still manages at least you
know intermittently to be threatening
what he has though is this like one like
ultimate soldier in a way yeah who is
pretty [ __ ] scary
like he was a good match for Thor in my
opinion like he was pretty [ __ ] cool
well yeah it's like he's the leader of
this idea and then he's got his general
yeah who was just a beast Menace yeah
just a beast you know and it's pretty
sick reason to see number 10 Chris
O'Dowd this guy has the best minute of
screen time you'll ever see I see you
Chris yeah I don't use he's apparently
he's like just a little side character
for Natalie Portman's character but he's
pretty [ __ ] funny he's charming and
he like every time he was on screen for
the good minute he had he was still like
what a charming [ __ ] yeah it's
like and if they were smart to choose
him because it's like he has such a
natural charm charisma everyman yeah
insecurity as well yes the perfect guy
for this little bitty role and it's just
so much fun to have him around cuz he
just does such a good job at it it's not
necessarily important but he's fun to
watch yeah that's good he's like my
favorite
they're like fibers characters but he
definitely shines reasons not to see
parts of the script there's some like
weird tonal shifts especially like we
talked about earlier with a humor but my
biggest script problems that have to
come a Natalie Portman's character she
is important she's definitely important
but she doesn't get as much screen time
and a screen time she has I had some
issues with it's in the trailer she gets
to Asgard
point and when she shows up she goes
this whole space traveling through
realms you know she's not a [ __ ]
astronaut or anything but when she lands
in this whole new planet full of life
she's just like that was sweet let's do
it again that was fun
yeah there's like no sense of wonder or
shock or fear which is what any human
would go through when you're traveling
through space yeah it's like she gets to
Asgard and then immediately they swap
her personality with Darcy it's like yes
are all Darcy's lines that now natalie
portman is for some reason the same so
if you guys don't remember Darcy is the
is gatherings attendings are the interns
Internet it's it's not it doesn't
detract heavily from the movie but there
is a good ten minutes or so where
everything she does is like these are on
principle the proper reactions but
you're saying they've like a completely
different character like and then when
she starts behaving like Thor's little
teenage girlfriend that's when I was
like what this seems so out of character
overall with the script my problems are
only minor like nothing that really
heavily detracted from the movie for me
but I sort of looking back on I feel
like a lot of the Earth's stuff isn't
really all that necessary other than
because we know who these people are
from the first movie it's like I wish
they gave us a little more to be like oh
this is why they're working together and
this is why we need to have them in the
movie they're kind of just there also
with the villain it's like I wish they
had given him a little more I wish
they'd made him just a bit more
threatening since we get so many of
these big superhero action movies is
that after a while it's hard to make a
villain feel truly threatening without
giving their actions huge impact and
it's like everything's leading up to his
master plan but I wish there was more
collateral damage or something like that
to make him a bit more truly terrifying
yeah the script you know that it's a
little rough in spot
Ryan's consensus another wonderful
addition to the Marvel cannon is the
reason to see Thor the dark world
another wonderful addition to the Marvel
Canon is the reason to see Thor the dark
world yeah it's just a great science
fiction fantasy adventure with a lot of
humor a lot of action and I just had a
total blast series consensus a fun comic
book epic is the reason to see Thor the
dirt world a fun comic book epic is the
reason to see Thor the dark world
you know it's like they take all that
stuff you wanted more of and they give
you more of it and it's like a full-on
sprawling you know fantasy epic movie
all right guys thanks for checking out
our review for Thor the dark world why
don't you go ahead scroll that comment
box below and tell us who's your
favorite Avenger and once you're done
with that once you come over here and
click on this button so you can see more
episodes and reasons to see and once
you're done with that once you go ahead
follow us on Twitter and like us on
Facebook and once you're done with all
that stuff maybe you want to get updated
every time a new review or a video is
out if you're a fan of the show well if
that's the case you're gonna wanna
subscribe click that button homies enjoy
yourself
that's right enjoy yourself while you're
clicking and we want it to be a fun
experiment while you're watching this
video I don't care yeah I mean whatever
it's the privacy of your own home I hope
yeah I mean if you're masturbating to us
while we're watching that's a [ __ ]
compliment yeah seriously I mean you
know don't do it on like a subway train
you know yeah I mean if you get good
reception on your foam layer in a subway
train but yeah I mean if you had fun
that good by all means you deserve to
masturbate ability yeah it's like yeah
okay creepy but flattering at the same
time
why don't you comment below and tell us
if you're masturbating to us